A hare is an animal that can run very fast.
A tortoise is an animal that can move only very slowly.
One day, a hare laughed at a tortoise that was moving slowly past him.
The tortoise, who did not like being laughed at because he was slow,...
...said to the hare, "Although you can run faster than I, I will beat you in a race."
The hare, thinking that the tortoise could not do this, said, "Very well, I will race you."
The two animals asked a fox to be the judge...
...and to choose the place for the race.
On the day of the race,...
...the fox told the animals where the race would begin and where it would end.
The fox then said, "One, two, three, go!" And the race began.
The hare ran off and was soon a long way in front of the tortoise.
He was so far in front that he stopped running to have a rest and soon fell asleep.
The tortoise, however, just kept on moving slowly forward.
When the hare woke up, he saw that the tortoise had passed him...
...and was now a long way in front of him.
He ran as fast as he could to catch up and pass the tortoise.
But before he could do this,...
...the fox judged the tortoise to be the winner of the race.